anh
alo chào các bạn
anh Alo ạ
ờ ờ
à à
từ hôm nay thì ỉa như các bạn đang thấy
là hôm nay sẽ ra nhảy sang cài khóa mới
đúng ạ hóa học bây giờ mình sẽ là lập
trình web chuyên sâu ở mình cũng vừa mới
đăng bài truyện dự tin k10 để mà thông
báo thời khóa học này Nhưng mà điều đầu
tiên thì mình cư chúc mừng ngày quốc tế
phụ nữ đã nóng lạnh
Ừ hi vọng là
các bạn nữ không rỗi mình bởi vì mình
mình đang thấy
kênh của mình đang
xe hơi hấp dẫn các bạn con trai hơn em
thực sự thì mình cảm thấy là những những
bạn con gà những bóng hồng mà học công
nghệ thông tin mới có gì đó kiểu thật sự
là kiểu ghê gớm và xịn nên là mình vẫn
rất mong kiểu dạng là các bạn nữ mà mang
theo ngành này thì sẽ
chị sẽ cậu không Không Lạnh không dễ bỏ
cuộc không Không chịu thua bất kỳ ai nào
ra mình con gái mình mình mà đã thích
cái gì còn mạnh mẽ hơn của mấy bạn trai
Cái đây tôi còn định được về phía tôi
cũng gặp khá nhiều bạn nữ học này cũng
niềm tin rồi
các em à cái điều mà các bạn đấy thường
hay mắc phải là các bạn đấy hơi bị tự ti
bạn nữ thường hay có tự ti hơn con trai
con trai thì nó mạnh bạo hơn Nó kiểu nó
không sợ nó không sợ say gì cả các bạn
nữ thì hai ý Chụp rẻ hợp hay bị sợ sai
hay hay sợ là kiểu mình làm cái đấy sẽ
bị ho nên là mình mong các bạn sẽ luôn
tự tin vào bản thân mình
Chào mừng các bạn nam thì mấy ông cũng
phải phấn đấu để cho các bạn nữ à
cho mấy bạn nữ nè Mình cũng như là các
bạn nữ kiểu tin tưởng được chứ mấy ông
Nam mà tôi đánh giá mấy hôm nay Mà kiểu
cũng rút về như các bạn nữ gì
thì thì
không biết thế nào không ạ
Ờ Ờ
nó qua về cái á
về lộ trình thì mình mới có đăng bài đó
là kiểu cái cái lập trình web chuyên sâu
này như mình đã từng hứa hẹn Đó là kiểu
là cây kênh đầu tiên là mục tiêu đã mục
tiêu làm chỉ là để cho các bạn sẽ đi làm
một phát được luôn Thậm chứ không cần
phải đi tập được bởi vì làm xong cái đầu
oán của cái khóa này thì các bạn sẽ hoàn
toàn dễ hiểu là là ở ngoài đang làm cái
gì các bạn nhảy vào bất kỳ website này
các bạn sẽ làm được cái đấy mình khẳng
định được
đấy cái mục tiêu hướng đến của cái khóa
học này nó như thế và Thậm chí các bạn
sẽ có thể nổ mức lương 5 triệu là ít
nhất và bảy tám triệu là mức của chuno
rồi còn Suneo thì mình sẽ cố dậy cho các
bạn vì mình cũng đang Nữa của Sino nói
Trung Hòa toàn bộ những cái mà gọi là
cực tinh hoa hay ở toàn bộ nhưng cái
kiến thức mà
gì tinh túy nhất những cái gì mà mình
mình ổn những ngày thứ duy Mình đang làm
mình sẽ chia sẻ cho các bạn nói cho mình
không giấu giếm một cái gì cả tài liệu
này xong rồi cả cơ hội nghề nghiệp hay
bất kỳ cái kiến thức gì có thể
A và đặc biệt đặc biệt cái này là cái mà
các bạn rất mong chờ các bạn rất thích
và nhiều người nhiều nơi không có đó là
các bạn hỏi được mình cái đấy rất là
quan trọng bởi vì à các bạn có người để
hỏi nếu mà các bạn theo về lauriel theo
cái mà mình đang dậy và các bạn vì sao
chuyên rau với nó thì các bạn sẽ có
người để hỏi cái quan trọng như thế Một
vì
đi làm mình từng đi làm mình mình may mà
mình ở từng có người kèm cặp nhưng mà
rất nhiều lúc mình không có ai để hỏi
mình rất là bất lực mình cảm thấy là
kiểu
kiểu dạng là cũng đã có suy nghĩ về việc
là
ý là không có khi mình chọn sai ngành
bởi vì là
thì đấy nghĩ em chỉ là không có ai hỏi
và mình cảm thấy mình tự học rất là mù
mờ mình đã từng cả mất rất nhiều sẽ mất
34 tuần chỉ nhìn vào những dòng code Rồi
sẵn sàng kiểu động não được ra cái gì cả
nên là bây giờ không những là mình phát
triển Cộng đồng để mà các bạn có thể tự
hỏi đạt sự trao đổi với nhau nói chuyện
trò chuyện tâm sự với nhau thì có quan
trọng là mình sẽ luôn ở đây để các bạn
có thể nhắn tin để mà hỏi hỏi bất kỳ cái
gì cũng được như các bạn có biết thì gà
Mình hỏi mình tâm sự tuổi hồng cũng được
nhưng mà Cái quan trọng là hỏi về công
việc cấp thứ thứ mình có công mình đã
từng làm cái gì thì mình cũng sẽ hỗ trợ
giúp được các bạn cái đấy
cho
nên cái đấy là một trong những cái mặt
mẹ nếu đi làm thì ông sẽ biết rất khó để
hỏi người khác và cũng như là họ họ có
mối quan tâm của họ không dành thời gian
nhiều cho ông đâu đúng không họ mấy ông
cho họ cái gì đúng không Vân Vân Vân họ
không rảnh để ngồi đi bước 2 giải cốt
cho ông đâu nên là nên là rất nhiều sinh
viên cũ của mình vẫn đến bây giờ đi làm
hai ba năm rồi vẫn còn nhắn tin hỏi mình
rất nhiều cái từ việc cơ sở dữ liệu cho
đến kiểu
kiểu nên áp dụng công nghệ gì hãy vân
vân nên là thực sự thì mình thấy cái
quan trọng nhất đi
ở cách đó là kiểu mình có người đi cùng
mình mấy ông các bạn không đi một mình
ông ạ Các bạn sẽ đi cùng mình và có
những bạn khác cùng đồng hành điều lấy
mới những người thứ rất là quan trọng
mình cảm thấy à Mình muốn đi nhanh thì
đi một mình không ạ Còn nếu muốn đi xa
thì thì đi cùng cùng mọi người cũng đi
cùng người khác nữa không ạ thì mình sẽ
đồng hành cùng các bạn
chắc chắn là nói chung à Tôi không bỏ
ngày ngày đâu Nên là chắc chắn nó sẽ đi
cùng các bạn đến cuối luôn đèo ngoạn
ừ ừ
tôi mà thôi mà tôi mà đi học đại học mà
tôi nghe được có một ai đó một kiểu như
thế thì tôi tự tin lắm tôi Cứ theo ngày
ngày đến cùng luôn
Em ở Nghệ ấm áp mà đúng không Tôi khẳng
định là vừa rồi giọng ngọt xớt nhưng mà
nó không phải đa cấp tôi từng thắng nào
3 cấp nhưng tôi khẳng định là tôi nói
cái gì cũng thầm thì thì tôi mới tự tin
bởi lời nói mới có trọng lượng như thế
đúng ạ Nó giống như đang tấp đấy Tôi
đang dụ dỗ các bạn theo tôi mà đúng ạ
Nếu quan trọng là tôi không lấy được gì
Các bạn cả mà tôi sẽ giúp Thế lòng các
bạn cùng lắm là các bạn thỉnh thoảng 10
tôi đi cà phê cũng được không ạ
chú Tư kiểu rất nhiều nơi tôi thấy kiểu
dậy xong thì họ Kệ luôn sinh viên kiểu
tao lấy được tiền của mày rồi Kiểu nói
chung mà đội đôi bên trao đổi buôn bán
kiểu kết thúc vào dịch rồi Thế là hết
ông ạ nhưng mà không Chúng ta không như
thế với nhau đó ngoại ý
khi chúng ta còn nói chung là tôi sẽ có
phấn đấu để về sau chúng ta còn cảm thấy
rất muốn nhìn mặt nhau rất muốn được gặp
nhau chứ không phải là nhé nhau đúng ạ
Ừ ok Nói chung là buổi hôm nay Mọi hôm
nay mình tự tin là hôm nay buổi sẽ rất
là đông nhưng mà
mình hôm nay mình sẽ dậy thứ nhất là
mình sẽ dùng bằng mụn bằng công cụ mới
có công cụ cả lý tháp này cà phê pass
tôm là ITA này và dạy qua mô hình RC
mình vẫn khẳng định nhé các bạn
Chúc các bạn học MBC ở bất kỳ Trang web
nào mà mình bởi vì mình đã từng lướt qua
rất nhiều trang web mình mình còn vừa
trao Google xong mình vừa chào Google
kiểu VC này mà cái xe là gì sang một
mmvc này này mình vừa ra xong này
Anh Bình cha của cả trang web nước ngoài
của cả Việt Nam đây nhờ không thể xem mà
hết nhưng mình cũng khẳng định là mình
dậy với xe dễ hiểu nhất cái cái mpc dễ
hiểu nhất tôi không khẳng định được tôi
dậy những cái khác có dữ liệu không
Nhưng hôm nay tôi khẳng định tôi dậy
công ông nào không hiểu thì thì
tội cho biết làm nữa không hiểu xem lại
rồi nhưng tôi khẳng định mà ai học xong
Cái hôm cái bộ hôm nay cũng dễ hiểu kỹ
càng người không phải dân công nghệ
không phải biết về lập trình cũng hiểu
tôi sẽ lấy ví dụ dễ hiểu à
anh ạ
ờ ờ
Ừ thì hôm nay mình sẽ còn mình sẽ thử
dùng cái tôn mà đó là like cốt nữa để
cho các bạn có thể vào xem cốt cùng kiểu
tôi cốt để lâu mà ông sẽ nhìn đến đấy
nhưng mà chính là nó miễn phí chỉ cho 50
người thôi tí thôi mà chia sẻ link mấy
ông Toàn nhanh không thì mấy ông mất
quyền lợi mày không hiểu thì thôi ông ạ
Đầu tiên là mấy ông phải cái face tôm
nữa nha Cái mà tôi đang dùng này mấy ông
sẽ cả cái tôm nhé
ở đầu tiên để tôi sẽ lên nha ý Tháp của
tôi đúng không Rồi tôi sẽ tôi sẽ đăng
một cái vipo với tạo một cái Zippo nghĩa
là tôi vẫn sẽ dừa và chia sẻ chia sẻ cốt
cho các bạn xem trực tiếp được tôi vượt
tạo Xipo và tôi sẽ đăng thường xuyên cốt
của tôi lên đây cốt để mô thôi chứ Cốt
không không copy để làm được gì cả cô để
mô để mà mua dạy học để mà mấy ông mấy
ông có thể kiểu vào tham khảo và học
đúng không ạ
à à Dùng ID nào cũng có thể học được cái
cái khóa học này không không phải là
pass tôm như tôi đâu chẳng qua cái ý tôi
là tôi thì sẽ chuyên dùng pass Tôn Đản
cả là tôi sẽ chia sẻ cái link để mà Mấy
ông có thể là xem cốc trực tiếp được bởi
vì vừa nãy tí tí nhá Tôi sẽ tạo ra tận à
Ví dụ là kiểu hai ba chục file chẳng hạn
thì tôi mỗi file gan nó chỉ vài dòng
thôi nhưng mà tôi sẽ không thể làm hiển
thị lên toàn bộ ba mươi mấy file ở trên
cái màn hình để mấy ông có thể xem được
không ạ
thì thì chắc chắn là mấy ông sẽ cần là
sẽ cần phải xem từng Thay 1 Ê mấy ông
tôi thì chắc chắn là cái việc là xem
like cốt là xem trực tiếp từ file của
tôi không cần phải đội tôi bấm vào từng
file để mấy ông xem thì nó sẽ tiện hơn
rất nhiều đúng ạ đấy nhưng mà đưa nhiều
Tổn sẽ tạo Xipo để cho mấy ông để tôi cứ
cốt một tí thôi sẽ đăng lên cái cái vipo
này rồi mấy ông xem trực tiếp từ kể cốt
từ Xipo cũng được nhưng mà nghĩa là tôi
cứ phải cốt xong rồi tôi đẩy lên kít
xong rồi mấy ông ấy xem được thì trong
lúc mà tôi đang cốt giờ tôi cho Để đến
đít thì mẹ em không xem được thì thôi
Ừ tôi cũng cố phấn đấu không hẳn là cổ
phần đầu như anh Độ nhưng mà nhưng mà
tôi cũng xem một vài khá nhiều cái video
hay của anh đấy và tôi sẽ cô phấn Đó là
truyền cảm hứng được nhanh đấy như tôi
không muốn nổi ngang nhớ kiểu tôi không
Tôi vẫn tự tin Tôi không muốn nổi lắm à
từ
khóa học này là sử dụng pp cụ thể về sau
sẽ Trung Quốc LED và kết hợp với
Pacquiao xong rồi à
gia Speed nữa
Ừ anh sẽ là web nâng cao ý
à à
ở
chung là tôi sẽ đăng mọi thứ lên cái web
nâng cao này
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ
nó cho tôi sẽ đang bận chút lên đây nhá
Mà tí rộn sẽ dạy tôi sẽ hướng dẫn về ông
về việc dùng vít việc đăng thông tin lên
get là nhưng mà mọi thứ như nào
anh làm sao để học được trình từ con số
0 thì mình thì mạch ông vào playlist của
tôi dạy SQL cơ bản rồi ông học à khóa cơ
bản trước nhé Còn hôm nay nâng cao rồi
ông vào đây ông bị choáng đấy
Ờ Ờ
mình có đang làm ở view và cụ thể là
Facebook mắt node.js nhưng mà mình là
Vì mình chưa Thảo nó lắm đây mà mình
cũng chưa có thể hướng dẫn các bạn được
Mình Nam vừa vừa làm ở trên công ty vừa
mò chủ yếu thôi chứ mình chưa chuyên sâu
nó cái thứ Minh chuyên sâu nhất Bây giờ
mình vẫn khẳng định đó là SQL và razzil
cái đấy mình hoàn toàn hệ dậy được các
bạn
à à
An đăng ký làm học viên á Không ông vào
đây học ở đó là hồng viên rồi nó nó xàm
có cần đăng ký không thì cả
ờ thì đầu tiên là tại sao hôm nay chúng
ta đã học 10 mvc mới với xe là gì Tôi sẽ
thời cha mày Ông nhá Mấy ông sẽ gõ mvc
và thêm chữ progaming này hoặc là patin
tức à Tên nó là kiểu dạng mà mô hình kẹo
kẹo như thế mô hình thiết kế đấy nếu
thịt gõ gì này xong rồi mấy ông là có
rất nhiều hình ảnh nhưng mà cái hình ảnh
tôi thích nhất đấy để tôi cho ông xem
nhé
Ê mấy ông sẽ thấy là ở đây có rất nhiều
nhảnh không ạ Và mấy ông mà xem hình ảnh
này mới cũng chàng hiểu lấy được tôi
khẳng định luôn mấy ông sẽ hơi bị khó
hiểu một tí à
Ừ cái hình này còn dễ thương đồ dễ hiểu
này nhưng mà không tôi sẽ không dậy mấy
ông qua những hình này tôi cũng sẽ vẽ
xong với ông thì hơi xấu một tí nữa sẽ
vẽ em với ông mấy ông thử nha Xem xem
mấy ông kê gà kể cả ông hôm nay hôm nay
ông mới tinh luôn Tôi khẳng định ông
hiểu đoạn này
ở đầu tiên thì hộp Bây giờ Bây giờ có
bài toán tình huống như này nhá chúng ta
vào tiết mục kể chuyện đi đầu tiên là
hôm nay là mùng 8 tháng 3 đúng không ạ
Mấy ông rủ bạn gái đi ăn thì đi ăn nhà
hàng không ạ thì mới ông sẽ
Ê mèo đen nhà hàng thì đầu tiên khi nào
mày ông vào nhà hàng thì không phải thì
luôn sẽ có một người bồi bàn chạy a kiểu
nhân viên chạy ra đón mấy ông rồi dẫn
ông vào bàn ngồi đúng ạ thì đây là sự
đây đâu mày
Em vừa phải có biến hình ở đây nữa thì
chả tôi sẽ không vẽ bằng cái này tôi sẽ
vẽ bằng à grow.io thì tôi sẽ xấu lắm đó
anh không vẽ gì mày ông đôi khi thích
hơn
chị sẽ vẽ Android VOV nó có sẵn cái á Nó
có sẵn cài ra gì
ở đoạn có tỷ lệ tí nhá
Trang Story
thiết kế web máy sẽ tự tại một đời sau
này
A tại nó sẽ có hình như này đó đây là
ông này không cần nói với bạn gái ông
đâu có khi ông đi một mình thôi
xe máy cẩu nha
anh anh sẽ ra ông này à anh
đúng không ạ
a tiếp theo là ông sẽ ra cái bàn đúng
không ạ Nó sẽ tôi sẽ cho vào đây một cái
là cái bàn
Ê bà này ông ạ ông sẽ ngồi ở đây không ạ
Đầu tiên ở nhân viên nó sẽ dẫn ông ra
cái bàn đúng chưa Sau đó thoảng nhân
viên để nhân viên này
à à
Ừ ông hôm nay mà vẫn còn ngồi đây xem
tôi dậy chứng tỏ Mấy ông không có đâu
trừ khi ông đang ngồi xem cùng người yêu
à
Ok bây giờ nhân viên nó dẫn ông ra cái
bàn xong ngồi đó làm gì hay hai người
ngồi ngắm nhau à đúng không Lúc này sau
đó thì nó sẽ làm gì
Ôi trời ơi nhanh thời nhanh bây giờ nó
sẽ làm gì à
Cho tôi chơi với người yêu về rồi ở
ngoài nhanh chứ tí nhà nghỉ cháy
Thế hả Bây giờ nhân viên sẽ làm gì hạ
khi mà ông ngồi xuống bàn rồi
Đúng rồi Đúng rồi bạn kia nói chuẩn luôn
Đưa menu đúng không ạ phải đưa máy lu
nữa chứ chị gọi món ông biết món gì
Đúng rồi Nghĩa lúc mà ông chưa gọi món
lúc mà ông chữa viêm món gì thì cái việc
đầu tiên nó là
anh đưa cho ngày mai new Đúng chưa đơn
giản mà không ạ
cho tôi sẽ đây sẽ có một cái bé bé ở đây
thì nó sẽ đưa vào một cái nóng ạ sẽ đưa
ông cái tôi sẽ vẽ tôi sẽ nối
à à
em thông cảm vẽ không có tốt cho làm nha
Kệ nha
từ ngày tôi sẽ nổi như này
Vì sao giờ này nó sẽ đây một cái máy ngu
đúng không ạ
cô gái mê uống rượu máy hay Bống chưa
điên nhà hàng vợ toàn còn bình dân lại
không có miru gì cả à
ờ ờ
a tiếp theo là đưa cho male to Male thì
ông sẽ làm gì ông như ông sẽ chọn món
xong nó gọi món đúng ngoại cho Ông đưa
menu không Ăn cái Menu đúng ạ Ông sẽ gọi
món Đúng chưa
Không bình thường bình dân cái Menu Tức
là nó dán như tưởng mày tự hỏi lòng
chẳng 10 bàn rồi đấy cậu sẽ gọi món đúng
không ạ
Cái này mấy cũng không hiểu tôi chịu nha
Thôi bảo hôm nay tôi khẳng định tôi dậy
dễ hiểu rất nhiều người dậy ai sẽ gọi
món gà sử Giả sử tôi gọi món đó sử là
hôm nay sang chảnh và bò bít tết đi sang
trọng ông mà không biết bò bít tết thì
nó bỏ mé này nó cho nam đấy ạ và đương
nhiên là ông sẽ gọi kiểu như này ông sẽ
gọi món bò bít tết rồi truyền truyền cho
bạn ấy nha Nhưng nhưng cái này là cái
hiện vật cái này tôi sẽ để hình khác thì
cho bé uống dễ hình dung kiểu Lời nói
thì tôi sẽ để ở nhà đi thật nhớ ai Tao
muốn bỏ bíttết ngủ ngon kiểu ngay
chú
bò bít tết
không tôi để cho cái hình gì nó dễ nghỉ
nè đi rồi Ok tôi để nhìn này đấy
bài hát Tôi ngồi dậy mấy ông ấy không
còn hỏi tôi chơi nhiều chưa
Ừ ông cậy tôi Vừa đụng chạm ông nếu đụng
chạm lại tôi đúng không Ok tôi sẽ gọi
món
các món bò bít tết em ạ sau đó thì thằng
Nhân viên nó sẽ làm gì nó sẽ nó sẽ ở lôi
trong túi thần kì của nó ra món bộ y tế
từ đưa tôi à Hay như nào bởi ông treo
mày theo mấy ông thì thằng Nhân viên sẽ
làm đi
ê ê
Khi Nào tập trung có việc là mấy ông kia
bị sao hôm nay học nghiêm túc Cận nhà
thôi nhưng vẫn học nghiêm túc
Ừ đúng rồi nghĩa là sẽ đưa cái nói chung
mà người ta gọi món gì thì mình sẽ ghi
lại đúng không ạ sau sợ mình sẽ đưa cái
đơn đấy xuống cho đầu bếp đúng ạ Chứ
không phải là kéo nồi bỏ guitar của máy
đây không chuyện đấy đúng ạ Đấy thì mình
sẽ tiếp nhận cái cái này thôi Sau đó thì
chuyển cho đầu bếp đúng rồi
Ừ cái này dễ mà đúng không đến đoạn này
mới hiểu nếu không hiểu chứ chị thì thì
đương nhiên hàng đầu bếp nó không phải
đứng cạnh thằng này được nó bọn nó sẽ ở
trong bếp Không ạ thì đầu tiên nó sẽ gửi
cái này
hai lọ truyền sang số để hạn truyền sang
nhà đi
đã sửa cái nó phải là nó phải cả mũi tên
Sang đây nữa nó Lười quá
sẽ chuyển sang trang web ở trong bếp
Không ạ
ừ ừ
anh tóc xanh
khi cậu bé bị đồ họa
thì đưa Mỏ năm thằng đầu bếp thì thì
thằng đầu bếp nó cũng không thể là nó
kiểu nó đưa lại cho thằng Nhân viên được
luôn đúng không ạ đúng không chị đưa cái
món ăn cho đầu bếp thì thì sàng đối Nó
sẽ phải làm gì tiếp theo
à à ừ ừ
em đưa rồi đưa thực đã đưa gọi đồ cho
đầu bếp đúng với bạn kia lại nói chuẩn
nữa lấy nguyên liệu rồi làm đúng không ạ
Đúng rồi phải lấy nguyên liệu đã mình
không nấu nấu mắt à cứ mở
cái vừa bếp lên nấu à phải đúng rồi phải
bạn bạn phải bảo với em nói chuẩn luôn
đấy nó lấy nguyên liệu rồi làm đúng
không ạ lấy nguyên liệu thì cứ sáng nào
sẽ lấy trong tủ lạnh không ạ Tôi sẽ có
một cái tủ lạnh ở đây để tủ lạnh này
chẳng sao mấy ông bảo nấu nấu cái gì
chẳng muốn nấu cái gì vậy nếu không sẽ
lấy cái gì từ trong tủ lạnh nhà Nếu
không phải lấy cá ra à Không sợ lời cái
gì nóng ạ mấy ông sẽ ở lại ở đây ra một
cái kiểu đấy
A gọi là mở tủ lạnh ra không ạ
Ừ dạo này sẽ là mở
tủ lạnh này mở này đúng không ạ Đấy sau
đó thì lấy ra cái gì đúng không
Ừ để bò Mỹ à sang chảnh ngoài bít tết
rồi phải bò Mỹ không ạ cô gái nó sẽ lấy
ra đây tôi sẽ có mũi tên đi từ mũi tên
nó dễ
chị sẽ lấy tay bò ruộng á ok đấy da bò
chứ không phải bò bít tết đâu nhá Không
không phải lấy ra nguyên bộ y tế phải
đưa thằng nhân viên không ạ Đấy chỉ thấy
da bò chưa chế biến thịt gà không ạ sau
đó Thì bây giờ mình mới chế biến đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ chế biến ok nó sẽ ở đây
là nó sẽ chế biến ở đây Tôi có một cái
đoạn ở đây là
ở đây nhìn này cho dễ đi nó sẽ làm nó sẽ
chế biến
ạ
sau đó nó sẽ quay lại đây là chế biến
đúng không ạ đời nhìn này
khi chế biến xong xong thành món bò kho
sau đó thì sau đó thì nó làm gì chế biến
xong rồi làm gì tiếp nó chạy chạy ra
ngoài bếp rồi nó đưa cho cho ông ăn à
Hay nó làm gì tiếp
bò ướp Chinsu
có vẻ ông theo dõi phạm vào đây
hai thằng nhân viên sẽ là thằng thằng
thằng lấy cái đấy là đưa cho mình đúng
không ạ Đúng rồi để làm chỉ là là thằng
nhân viên nó sẽ lấy đúng không Thằng
nhân viên ở đến lấy đầu tiên ở đây sẽ
đưa đưa đưa kiểu yêu cầu đúng ạ Đấy được
yêu cầu cụ thể là yêu cầu bò đúng không
ạ sau đó Cái gì lần thứ hai nó đến nó sẽ
đến lấy
đi hoa cà hoa cà thằng đầu bếp nó cũng
chủ động đưa cho đi ở đầu bếp chủ động
đưa đi là
thì nó sẽ đưa lại cho thằng Nhân viên nó
không Cái quan trọng ở đây cái hay mà
tôi đang chuẩn bị nói nó không đưa theo
kiểu là nó cầm tay để mà đưa đưa miếng
bò Của mày đây nó không cầm bằng tay
đúng không ạ Nó sẽ cầm bằng đĩa thì bọn
nó sẽ để lên cái đĩa rồi nó đưa cho nhân
viên không ạ thì ở đây nó sẽ là
anh ở đây Tôi có một cái nữa Ở đây
thế này nó sẽ nó sẽ là cái đĩa
Dù chưa
Ừ nó nó sẽ đưa cho thằng Nhân viên cái
đĩa này đương nhiên đĩa này chị sẽ không
đĩa này sẽ đĩa gồm cả bò nhé phải cái
đĩa không nữa nhé đúng ạ là nó sẽ đưa
thằng Nhân viên của địa danh này
anh
nói kiểu này sao rồi Thảo nhân viên nó
sẽ làm gì nó sẽ Đừng để nó ăn luôn à Thế
nó làm gì
Ừ nó đương nhiên nó sẽ đưa lại nốt cái
đĩa này cho ông đó ông ạ Đúng chưa đấy
thì nó sẽ chuyển lại ngay cho khách rồi
kìa Thôi tôi cứ để tạm đây rồi méo hiểu
các bạn đoạn sau tiếp nhé Thi a a thôi
tối nghĩa cứ ghi hạn rõ ra đi rồi thêm
phát nữa đi
à mà không Nếu thế thì tôi trong trường
hợp này tôi sẽ để đây là thằng ngày Đưa
cho nó chỉ có bò bít tết thôi
ở trận đợi tí thì cha tôi sửa lại caro
Dạo này tý hợp lý nhé thằng thằng nhân
viên này nó đến lấy đây tôi sẽ dùng cái
khái niệm này cho nó dễ đi nó để lấy
em lấy bò bít tết chuẩn là như thế này
nó hợp lý hơn này
Có ai có chuẩn bị xong rồi sau đó thì
thằng Nhân viên nó sẽ
em trả lại cho ông một cái là
anh ạ
ca nhạc không chụp hình này
ổ đĩa bò bít tết
sốt trở lại
khi
đến đoạn này thì tôi khẳng định là béo
đều hiểu cái quy trình này nó rất là dễ
Tại sao tự nhiên tôi dậy Cái này đang
đói thì đã cả đang đang fa không đi nhà
hàng được nhưng mà cái này nó chính là
mô hình mới với C đó chính là mô hình
mvc để ông ạ đây tôi sẽ cho ông xem tôi
sẽ nối lại tôi xin phép tôi nói lại cái
đoạn này sẽ cho nó hoàn thiện đi
anh nói chính là mô hình mới xe đấy
Ừ cái này mà không có dễ hiểu không Mày
cũng không hiểu nữa tôi chịu
cái mô hình mới sau đó là như thế nào
mua thì mua xe tất cả
Ừ ông Tư là một khách hàng không ạ Ông
có chạy treo b để tôi hỏi nhé ông có
chạy theo thằng nhân viên từ đầu đến
cuối để biết được là
chuyện gì đang xảy ra trong bếp hay là
mọi thứ nó xảy ra như thế nào ạ
à à
gì hả mày Mày Ông có chạy xe phải nhân
viên không Mày không có điều chỉnh kiến
từ đầu đến cuối Chiều thằng đầu bếp nó
mua lửa nhau
bạn trong trường hợp này không đúng
không ạ Trừ khi ông chơi kiểu ăn nhà
hàng xóm chỉ gỡ nó sẽ chế biến trực tiếp
theo trước mặt ông con không được cho
Thường mấy ông vẫn ngồi yên lại chỗ thôi
đúng ạ thằng nào là thứ hai và thằng nào
hoa chạy nhiều nhất nãy giờ
à thằng đầu bếp nhà hàng bếp chạy nhiều
nó chạy là cái tủ lạnh đúng không ạ
ở ngoài thằng nhân viên đúng không ạ Ok
mày không trả lời thế tốt hơn sinh viên
cũ rồi Tiếp theo là thằng đầu bếp nó có
chạy đi đâu ngoài bếp không nó chạy ra
ngoài không Nó kiểu chạy ra ngoài ngắm
xem
mặt mũi thằng ấy 3 như nào
anh không đúng bọn nó sẽ ngồi yên ở
trong bếp thôi không ạ và thằng đầu bếp
nó sẽ
Ừ nó nó sẽ kiểu gần như nó sẽ chỉ có
nhiệm vụ là làm việc với cái tủ lạnh và
nó sẽ chế biến thằng nhân viên nó cũng
không được động vào cái tủ lạnh nó không
được kiểu nhảy vào chế biến cùng thì
không hiểu Mày nấu dở quá không không ạ
Mỗi hàng nó sẽ có nhiệm vụ riêng của nó
bé là kiểu đấy là kiểu dạng mà quy chuẩn
của kiểu công việc của nhà hàng hay giấy
đúng thi thì cái mô hình mvc nó là như
thế Nó là kiểu trong trường hợp này ông
tức là khách hàng tôi sẽ đổi hết tên nó
bằng tiếng Anh Mỹ nhiều và ông sẽ dễ
hiểu hơn nhá
thế này nó frien nó khách hàng chưa Cái
bàn này lúc đầu thì thì tức à nó sẽ tôi
sẽ thử Anh gọi nó lại inject tất cả lúc
đầu khi mà ông và ông sẽ nhìn thấy cái
trang thủ trang chủ một cái trang cậu
mặc định khi mà mới ông vào ông sẽ nhìn
thấy nó và cái máy lu thì đương nhiên nó
hơi men vui thôi tất cả áo chị ạ là khi
mà khách chưa gọi đồ gì cả thì mình sẽ
cho họ xem cái máy nude để mà khách có
thể bấm vào bấm vào cái Menu để mà chọn
hay chọn lựa các thử thứ đấy cái bò bít
tết tất cả cái yêu cầu của ông yêu cầu
lên thằng cắn trợ thằng nhân viên sẽ
chính là thẳng container
ở đây đã sửa tí nữa nó là controller tức
là thằng điều hướng thằng xử lý thằng
thằng trung chuyển trung gian giữa tất
cả những cái đấy Ông thấy là khi mà
thằng nhân viên nó đưa menu cho ông nó
có phải vào hỏi ý kiến hàng đầu bếp
không đúng không nó cần phải vào hỏi ý
kiến thằng đầu bếp không kiểu chạy vào
kia bảo thằng đầu bếp đưa menu rồi đưa
ra ông không đúng không Nghĩa làm chỉ là
trong một vài trường hợp khi mà khi mà
kiểu được yêu cầu của gọi món khi các sở
hữu thì nó mới cần phải vào bếp để nó
yêu cầu thông được bế thôi đúng ạ thì
trong một vài trường hợp chờ xử là kiểu
đưa menu đấy hai đón khách cái tiếng
khách thì nó cần gì phải gọi không đầu
bếp không ạ nghĩa là thằng nhà hàng này
không phải lúc nào nó sẽ gọi hoặc nước
hết thằng đầu bếp sẽ chỉ được gọi khi mà
có can thiệp việc lấy dữ liệu ra từ cái
tủ lạnh thực và cần phải xử lý gì đó
thằng đầu bếp sẽ thằng mua đồ nó tủ lạnh
này trứng là cái mình đã học nó đã tờ
bầy là lấy dữ liệu ra nó sẽ kết nối cơ
sở dữ liệu lấy dữ liệu ra sau đó thì xử
lý dữ liệu Tất Cả chế biến rồi thằng
controller nó sẽ lấy cái dữ liệu đấy rồi
nó sẽ trả về cái đĩa bò bít tết đúng ạ
Cái đĩa bò đi Tết này nó sẽ chính là
view đấy vào cái bò bít tết vừa nãy tôi
vào thì nó sẽ gái gọi Quét tất cả yêu
cầu
đấy Đây là toàn bộ toàn bộ mô hình mvc
đây thì ông sẽ thấy mờ với xe nó sẽ viết
tắt của bờ này ở VN view này và còn chữ
L đấy nó sẽ có thêm những cái nữa nhưng
mà người ta không đề cập đó là thật Bây
này đó là kiểu request này đấy
A và Bryan cranston hiện nhân có ơi
chẳng cần đề cập gì cả
thì thì cái mô hình mua xe nó thế hả
nhân viên và họ đầu bếp có nguyên liệu
Không á tự đóng cửa ngay khi chơi đưa
menu kiểu
vào hỏi xem còn gì ăn không
thì thì cái mô hình OSI đó sẽ cảm như
thế này và bây giờ tôi sẽ chuyển qua nó
thành cốt để em béo dễ hiểu hơn không ạ
Nếu không có hiểu được nãy tôi vừa nói
gì không
Em không hiểu nữa vẫn là quay lại xem
video nhé
chịu nổi dậy thế chị cà phê thôi không
hơn được
Ông Ông lên mạng mà cho em một cái xe
người ta giải thích nghèo do dịch lý
thuyết vãi chưa ạ
Ờ thì đầu tiên là bây giờ tôi sẽ làm
đúng lại đúng như thế này cho mấy ông dễ
hình dung hơn theo dạng cốt nghĩa là tôi
mới vào tôi sẽ nhìn thấy cái Trang Trang
chủsản hạn đúng ạ thì thì sau đó thì
thằng thằng một thằng nào đó sẽ đưa tôi
cái máy lu không ạ Sau đó tôi sẽ gọi món
xong rồi nó sẽ trả về cho tôi cái món
đúng không ạ Đấy thì nó sẽ như làm đầu
tiên Các bạn thấy đó là đầu tiên ở sẽ
phải tạo Index này để lúc đầu khách hàng
vào sẽ nhìn vào cái fake không ạ sự mình
mình tạo file à
u&i rec.pro mình dùng ngôn ngữ p mà đấy
Ở
trang này mình sẽ lúc đầu nó là
chàng chủ kiện Nghe tiếng đàn này thôi à
anh
về sau sẽ đau não cái vừa vào vừa vào
tôi sẽ dậy kiểu nhà nhà nó vừa vào đau
não rồi Nếu mà rèn
em lấy mấy cái cái ổ công nghệ à mày cái
tôn tôi đã dùng rồi tôi sẽ không nói lại
mấy ông là cái này cái gì không nhé bởi
vì một phần là mày không phải biết qua
về khóa cơ bản thôi đã chứ hôm nay nhảy
nâng cao làm sao ngày được không ạ
khi
phát lại cái này mà này Không nhận à
shopee trả lời vậy
a web nâng cao đúng ở nhà
Ừ thôi không sao tôi sẽ vào local hóa
Vậy
moet nâng cao
đó lúc đầu sẽ vào trang chủ đúng ạ
ờ ờ lúc đầu sẽ ra trang chủ chỉ là này
thôi
em à đợi tôi một tí nhá Đợi tôi tôi xin
phép trừ phép một tí đó tôi sẽ chia sẻ
cái tôi sẽ mở kẹp Fall In Love In A
Ừ mai cốt để mấy ông có thể xem cốt được
luôn bây giờ cuối vãi chưa được 170 mấy
người điên à Vâng tôi sẽ
cho tôi sẽ chia sẻ cái Nếu mày ông đã
cài pass tôm thì phải có không nhớ là
mấy ông cần cài không ngờ nhưng mà thằng
pê tôm này sẽ có cái blog in liked
Ờ để mấy ông có thể xem cốc trực tiếp
được với tôi là cốt Bịch ni ở phải là
cốt thì ở chỗ không Ờ ờ để nếu có thể
xem được là tôi đang cốt
phải đâu luôn các thứ thì thành ra là
rất là tốt việc là bị bây giờ tôi tạo
nhiều file lắm nên là mấy ông xem xem
được cùng tôi thì tốt nếu hiểu không
a nay có thêm hợp cho cả vịt dạy học
những cái này là nó khá bắt đấy nên tôi
chỉ có bản miễn phí chắc chắn rồi
à Tôi đang dạy miễn phí mà nên không thể
đòi hỏi gì đó được thì thì đã cả bạn mua
thằng này nó vừa đắt nó vừa không hỗ trợ
được đông đến thế bây giờ 180 thôi điên
đấy thì thì
Ừ để tôi xem nhé tôi sẽ tôi sẽ chỉ cần
tạo một cái link Tôi nhớ không lầm mà
chỉ cần tạo cái Linh là có nhiều làm
người Ông thể xem cũng được
ca cổ tích Mỹ A
vì tình yêu tôi cài rồi Đúng rồi tôi cài
được nữa tôi từng cái được
Ừ thôi chưa dùng nó bao giờ đâu nên là
bây giờ tôi sẽ ngồi mò của méo có thể
hơi mất một thời một tí thời gian nhưng
đôi khi tôi thích cái kiểu đấy tôi tôi
sẽ không chuẩn bị gì cả tôi sẽ ngồi mò
cùng mấy ông để mấy ông cũng thấy là
kiểu dân công nghệ nó sẽ mò mấy cái thứ
này nó như thế nào
a what I'm này
ở cụm III
em đọc thử getting started
teacher-student này đã lại cái thứ mình
đang chuẩn bị này Và thậm chí còn bắt
người khác theo dõi mình có cái tính
năng này vải thường nghe thôi à
Ừ cái này cứ nói về Lysine đấy nhỉ Tôi
không biết được nghe luôn
anh ở đây đây đây
install này tôi 3 click cái biểu tượng
rồi
anh ở đây biểu tượng đây
Anh nhớ nhé B tôi chia sẻ link mà có nhà
ông nào vào nhanh chỉ cho 50 người vào
rồi đấy thế nên là thế nên là
cho
nên là bây giờ tôi sẽ để nó tiện cho mấy
ông thì tôi sẽ à
cho tôi Tôi sẽ mở cái Google Mít khi mà
một ông ở đó sẽ vào được vào được cái
này thì mới ông ấy chia sẻ màn hình hộ
tôi phát
để mà ông đấy sẽ hỗ trợ cho bạn khác
muốn đọc file gì thì ông ấy sẽ mở file
đầy lên cho bạn ấy đọc cho bạn lớp
trưởng làm hội tụ đấy nhá Anh ấy Thế lớp
trưởng bạn ô tội tạo hộ anh mít cả quản
lý cái mít đấy hộ anh luôn đi
Âm Nhạc
cách tạo ảnh Mỹ Pháp
à à
ờ
ờ discord hình như lần trước mình xem
this code nó cũng chỉ giới hạn cho người
xem người xem chia sẻ màn hình chỉnh 50
thôi nên là không nên là mấy lần mình
dậy mình mình kiểu làm về cái vụ kia
mình toàn bài à mình phải dùng dùi Mít
đấy mít discord nó bị giới hạn đấy
à à
Ừ
Ông lớp trưởng đi rồi à
Ừ cái cái cái luôn đi cả nhanh mà
thế hả Cái này đúng rồi mình sẽ dạy các
bạn lập trình thiên về bác em
Ừ đúng rồi Cái vs Cốt nó có cái cốt là
cái like cốt nhưng mà viết Cốt nó cũng
như thế thôi nó cũng nó cũng giống hết
là mấy ông phải mất tiền thì nó mới kiểu
cho tăng thời gian hơn đây tôi tôi tôi
tra rồi mà lại cốt vs Cốt
một ngày bây giờ tôi tra rồi tôi tôi tôi
còn sẵn sàng có thể sang viết code để
cốt để miễn là cho là mấy ông có thể xem
cốt của tôi Nhưng mà tôi thấy là nó bằng
nó bằng với cái thằng courtney là nó chỉ
giới hạn một lượng người đấy thôi nên là
thôi tôi dùng chụp dùng cái này quen rồi
nên tôi dậy Cái này thôi
Ừ ừ trên chia nhiều rôm cũng được như ý
ý mình là mình muốn cho mọi người chỉ
xem một lần mình hay sẽ một người nữa
thôi chứ việc nhiều người cùng chia sẻ
quá nó bị loạn
Ê mày méo hiểu không Ừ đúng rồi mấy ông
dùng cái pp stone này nó sẽ nặng hơn
Viết cốt nhưng mà nặng hơn nó sẽ có tiện
hơn mùi vài cái đặc biệt là cái này thì
ra còn mất phí nữa vé cốt thì miễn phí
nhưng mà cái này thì mấy ông có thể đăng
ký bằng mail edu thì nó miễn phí hoàn
toàn nên à Nên là mấy ông đang là sinh
viên thì ra mấy ông vẫn nên dùng cái này
và máy lên ram nó không phải hơi lớn lớn
một tí mới nên dùng còn kho mình mấy ông
dùng ghép cốt được
nhưng mà bởi việc tôi bảo tôi chuyên cái
này hơn nữa tôi không thể hiểu vì mấy
ông ấy sang Việt cốt số tối học lại từ
đầu thì lúc đấy Tôi cũng không biết dạy
Nếu gửi gì đúng không vì tôi phải anh
chia sẻ những cái thứ tôi truyền chứ
Ừ ừ đúng rồi tôi thu viết tốt nữa nhưng
mà bây giờ tôi đã tạm gạt sang một bên
đấy mày không Đừng có nói thế tôi buồn
đấy
à à
Em à bây giờ tôi sẽ
ở đây Linh ơi Linh ngày mấy ông có thể
vào xem mà cốt của tôi tôi tôi không
biết được và xem như thế nào đâu nhé Ê
mày ông có thể đây
get started to get này bấm vào link này
nó sẽ cho ông Download này một khi
download thì nó sẽ
à à hot chấp nhận ông Android xong rồi
nói rồi được rồi thì sẽ xem được Tôi
nghĩ là cái việc cho này sẽ là là cái
việc tạo link này sẽ là vĩnh viễn đấy
Tôi nghĩ là sẽ tạo Linh kiểu vĩnh viễn
đấy nên là
cho nên làm vì ông và nhanh bây giờ thì
về sau sẽ được tôi nghĩ thế tôi nghĩ
à à
Ờ Ờ
mình đã từng dùng cái đi bố của thằng
pashto mày rồi nó có công cụ đi bác ở
đây ngon tại mình đã từng dùng rồi nhưng
mà mình lại quên mất cách cài rồi mình
cũng nhờ anh ở trên công ty cày thôi
thằng này thằng nó lại ID mà lấy nó hỗ
trợ việc đi bắt rất tốt mà con dừng tại
dòng cốt nào đó Thử như ra Quyết Vân
tiện phết
anh không mình không phải là người tạo
ra Alex Anh xin lỗi chú tim mình có có
tức là Messenger không phải máy ếch xanh
bên chiếu tím
ừ ừ
ở
trên mít không hiện màn hình á đây bảo
bạn ạ Bạn lớp trưởng bạn chia sẻ màn
hình thôi
Ông xã bạn đang bận một tí để bảo bạn
đấy bảo bạn đấy chia sẻ màn hình đi Ừ
rồi à
à à
các bạn bạn ấy chia sẻ màn hình sau đó
thì
mày mày ông yêu cầu người ông cài ông
yêu cầu mở cái file gì thì bạn ấy Mở hộ
mấy ông để ông xem thì thấy còn tôi sẽ
tập trung dậy bên này Nói chung là đoạn
cài đặt này nó hơi bị mất công một tí
anh ở đây có vài bạn vài bạn xin vào rồi
đấy Ok Thế bạn lấy xem được file cốt của
tôi rồi
à à
Em
ở làng ấy tuổi đi mô tả là tôi sẽ empty
bitol nè Sao vậy bé cốt này
à Xong rồi hàng Apple này tôi sẽ còn
những cái mô tả thế trong trong cái lịch
sử của tôi mới đúng
ờ ờ
à à
ở cốt chua cay giờ cũng được có chút E
rồi Hình như là cũng là của ve cô đúng
không nặng như thôi như thế thôi không
không không maythu thì đúng là phi một
năm thôi nhưng mà nó là gia hạn 1 năm
sau nó sẽ lại gửi mail cho mấy ông ấy
không ra hạn lại cái này thế tôi vẫn
đang dùng cái miễn phí mà chúng phải
merdu để mấy ông sẽ miễn phí trọn đời
không trên đấy nó sẽ luôn một năm sau nó
hỏi lại ông nên là ông thầy cũng có
nhiều cách mà bơ có nhiều tra còn giả là
giảm urdu cơ
Ừ tôi không hẳn khuyến khích người ông
làm mấy cái Thế nó hơn vi phạm bản quyền
tí nhưng mà nếu không hiểu kiểu mình
đang sinh viên thì mình dùng thôi
khi hòa vào ông nào ở trên Mít ông nào
mà đã cài cái pass tôm này có thể chia
sẻ màn hình hộ đất trưởng đến lớp trưởng
chưa cài TP xôm kìa OK nhá trong đại
khái thế Bây giờ tôi bắt đầu dậy đi à
Ừ tôi không biết về cái vụ dùng mail cho
dialup ơ luôn à
khi tôi bắt đầu nha Thì nói chung à
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ quay lại đây mình sẽ
mình có phải đây rồi đúng không ạ Mình
sẽ cần có một và nhân viên để đưa ra đưa
mình là menu đúng không ạ Mình sẽ đây
mình sẽ tạo một file mới mình sẽ tạo
thành mới lại lưu đúng không ạ phải đây
mình sẽ mình sẽ thằng nhân viên mình nó
là controller hiểu chưa Nhưng mà tôi cứ
đặt à Thôi tôi cho mấy ông làm quen
trước tiếng Anh này đi
từ hạt đậu xanh cứ mấy ông cứ vào thành
ra không nó mất luôn cái của tôi ạ cần
trả lời chấm TP này
hai tay Ờ file này nó sẽ chỉ là pp thôi
nhớ nhá riêng mình cái file riêng mấy
file control và file-model nó sẽ chỉ có
pp thôi Nếu tôi sẽ mở luôn đây lúc đầu
là TP luôn cái mày không dễ hiểu Lúc đầu
thì nó sẽ
nó sẽ trả về cho ông một cái Menu đúng ạ
thì tức là nó sẽ bản chất cái Menu này
nó là cũng là một cái view không phải
mỗi cái đĩa thịt bò review đâu mà cái
Menu này là một cái view thế là nó sẽ
trả về cậu một cái bưu Tôi sẽ tạo một
cái file mà file menu này FPT này
ở đây tôi sẽ ở đây làm menu nha Chẳng ạ
Cái to thể H1 đi cho nó to trong anh
chán đi
ờ ờ menu kê chưa ấy thôi thằng
controller nó sẽ nó sẽ kiểu
anh trả về cho ông cái Menu Tức là nó sẽ
khái niệm là nó sẽ in Plus sẽ kiểu chèn
lại cái file menu cho bé ông như thế này
à
để tạo hình cho tôi vừa
hủy hủy Quyền truy cập của một ông ông
ông sim lại nha
và hiển thị lên nó không có về auto khó
chịu thật thằng này đã phải có cái auto
Chấp nhận đi nữa thì tôi xem Cài đặt đây
mà
em có cái nút là yêu cầu tất cả mọi
người theo dõi mình
coi như tôi không
có chữ nghỉ thỉnh thoảng lên cái Thảo
làm ngay tệ vậy
khi tôi thấy ở nó chỉ có như này thôi bé
ông ạ Không có mẹ ô tô gì cả đợi tí nhé
một tí một tí nữa chị ạ
a
Smart cái gì chẳng có smart ở đây rồi à
à à
bộ đội đi nhá costs with me how to
access restore
xem thử nào
em không có không có
em không có không treo tù gì đấy
xe ô tô download
ô
chữ nhật
anh không không có em ạ
ở đầu cốt đẹp
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ khi em mới vào
như này xong rồi nó chả phải ông cái
Menu nhờ ông thử xem tôi thử tại trai
nhé đồng thời điều đó chẳng có gì cả nó
vẫn là
so với Messi nữa
ở đây
Xem phim Only very làm gì có gì ông địt
tôi
Anh đang sửa auto-start vôi có thôi
anh đi Có gì alo
có ai mà ông muốn cho Phun tiền mà ngồi
sát vai của tôi
từ hạt i caught with me loa ok à
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là lúc đầu mấy ông vào mấy ông
vẫn chỉ nhìn thấy cái trang chủ
mấy ông vẫn cậu vẫn chưa nhìn được cái
Menu đúng ạ thì tại sao như thế bởi vì
Ê mấy ông sẽ phải gọi thằng con trả lời
này nữa Nhưng tôi sẽ ở đây sẽ có khác và
anh và hãy nhớ lúc đầu là thằng thằng
Nhân viên là thằng đưa ông kể đưa ông ra
đến cái bàn chứ không phải ông tự đến
cái bàn nên Tức là lúc đầu thực ra là
là nó không nó không đưa cho ông cái
kiểu dạng là
một phát kiểu như này đâu mà không phải
gọi đến rằng nhân viên hội thảo nhân
viên đưa với bàn nữa nên là cái file
crack này thường nó cũng sẽ không phải
phải view nó sẽ cũng chỉ là file pp và
nó sẽ là gọi đến hoặc nhân viên như này
đó như này
à à
ô tô tải trang này đó thì bây giờ tức là
sao Nghĩa lúc đầu vào ông vào cái bàn
này ông gọi hoặc nhân viên này thằng
nhân viên nó sẽ nó sẽ
đây tôi sẽ ở đây tôi còn split để mà cho
mấy ông xem được 1 vài file thôi tôi có
nhưng mà không xem được
chụp file cùng một lúc luôn nhá Nhớ là
có cái
a Beer
lieugiai nhắn tin
à à
ở đây xem tặng wifi Cùng một lúc rồi nhé
à
từ lúc đầu là lúc đầu ông sẽ gọi nhân
viên nha phòng nhân viên nó sẽ trả về
Menu cái Menu là cái này đúng không đơn
giản đúng không Đó được chưa mà chỉ có 3
file thôi đúng không tiếp theo
a tiếp theo nha là
là đương nhiên là ông không thể nhìn cái
menu trong trơn này đường ống sẽ gọi món
đúng không ạ
Ừ ông sẽ phải bấm vào món này ông gọi
đúng ạ giống như ở ông và mỗi trang web
bất kỳ nó có một Liệt kê một loạt menu
ra ông bấm bấm vào ví dụ là bây giờ tôi
sẽ có món bò bít tết hay là bỏ gì ấy
đúng không ạ thì tôi ở đây sẽ bản chất
nó sẽ là đường Minh thẻ này sẽ có khái
niệm là bò bít tết này nghe chẳng hạn
đấy nhưng bây giờ phải cần bấm và và bấm
vào thì sẽ là gì sẽ gọi đến một cái gì
đó cả như này có cần bấm vào thì không
phải bấm vào nó nó lại trả lại ông em em
nuôi nhà ấy cũng được đúng ạ Ông cần bấm
vào thì tớ ông yêu ông gửi cái yêu cầu
bò bít tết lên cho nó nhân viên để nhân
viên nó nhận diện tức là khi mà ông gửi
lên thì ông sẽ khái niệm này tôi sẽ gửi
lên một cái quét bất kỳ Tôi sẽ đặt tên
là món lạ món
anh bằng bò bít tết như này đã nạ
để không dấu với nó dễ lại như này tôi
tải lại trang này đó mấy ông thấy bây
giờ có thể bấm vào này thì nó sẽ truyền
lên gọi cái món là món bò bít tết đúng
không ạ thì khi gọi món bò bít tết rồi
thằng nhân viên có loại đưa lại ông ấy
lùi gọi lại tiêu không như thế nào Không
đúng ạ thì lúc này nó sẽ làm gì khi mà
ông gọi xong món thì nó sẽ phải sẽ cắt
cái Milo đi và nó sẽ nó sẽ tiếp nhận cái
đơn của ông rồi nó đưa cái đơn của ông
cho thằng controller Thành đầu bếp để
thằng đầu bếp đó xử lý đúng ạ Mấy ông
nhớ những cái đang xanh này không ạ Nói
sau hơn nửa tiếng cho quên hết rồi ông ạ
thì tất cả mấy ông cần đón nhận cái này
không ạ thì trong trường hợp này thứ
nhất ông không trả về Menu nữa đó không
phải chia trường hợp ra khi gọi món rồi
thì không đưa menu nữa còn đã gọi món mà
chưa gọi món thì mới đưa menu đúng không
ạ thì mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ có khái niệm
là ít nếu mà đầu tiên là nếu mà MT là
nếu mà trống Nếu mà trống
a dollar get món
Ừ nếu mà chóng món như thế này như thế
này nghĩa là không hề là lúc đầu chưa
gọi món thì sẽ trả về cái menu con em là
ngược lại này thì sẽ trả về một cái gì
đó không ạ Rồi chưa ạ Lúc đầu nếu mà
chưa Vợ món chả về Menu này còn nếu cậu
về tôi thử tại lại cho anh nhé đó nếu
không sẽ thấy mất cả menu rồi đúng không
ạ sẽ nhờ vào kệ em này Đấy được chưa đấy
thì trong trường hợp này thì bây giờ
mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ không như tôi đã
nói không phải thằng nhân viên nó trả về
luôn cái đĩa thịt bò thằng này không ạ
Nó sẽ phải nhận cái yêu cầu này Đầu tiên
nó phải nhận yêu rồi đã đúng ạ Rồi nó
đưa yêu cầu đấy cho thằng đầu bếp và
thằng bồ không ạ Nó sẽ nhận yêu cầu bằng
cách là món sẽ vàng Đó là các món này
tôi dùng cái tiện ích tự động tự động
viết code mà ông thấy nó gợi ý ngon
không một phát xong luôn không cần nghĩ
đấy sau đó thì nó nhận món nó đưa cho
bằng này tức là nó gọi đến hàng ngày anh
sẽ gọi đến thằng Moda này nó sẽ như thế
này mình sẽ tạo ra một xe nữa Tháng mua
đồ
a Model đ.tp
rồi Như tôi đã nói đó là phải controller
và Phan Model sẽ chỉ có pp thôi nên là
không có thil thì cả mở đầu five luôn
đấy mình sẽ gọi gọi thằng đầu bếp Mình
sẽ in Plus thẳng bộ đồ pê tất là thành
web ngoạn thằng đầu bếp trong trường hợp
này nó sẽ làm gì nó sẽ hiểu nó sẽ kiểu
mở mở cơ sở liệu để mà lấy ra món bò
đúng ạ thì thì bây giờ tôi sẽ tạo cơ sở
liệu
ô tô ở sẽ tạo nhé
ở phần control rồi cuộn chuột
mấy ông phải vào bên setting của thằng
thằng này để mấy ông làm cơ
khi
mở này rồi nghỉ tí tôi dùng Tuấn cái này
cho tiện
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ
tôi có không không không phải cái này tớ
tạo hẳn một cái đặt ấy mới đi
wallet.biz
to school Hạ
Ừ nó thôi tội F5 lại cái này ok rồi
bố mẹ tôi sẽ tạo bảng nếu khiếu tại bà
không Bây giờ tôi sẽ tạo bảng
A ông Nghĩa tôi sẽ ra con hấp ạ Không
chẳng lại làm thế phải mở ẩn danh mà
phải dùng bằng điện thoại xe bằng máy
tính
led table đấy mình sẽ có bạn ở bằng món
ăn này ạ món ăn mình sẽ có mã này tự
động tăng được cái mã không còn chậm lắm
đúng không ạ ạ
a cho in này How to implement
a tiếp theo là tên món ăn này sẽ ra tra
này 50 chỗ ạ
À mà thôi có khi tôi chỉ đơn giản đơn
giản nghe thôi tôi còn một tên này có
rảnh thì thôi tôi làm rất đơn giản cho
mấy ông thấy Hiệp tôi có ảnh hạn 200 đi
tôi chỉ có mỗi thế này thôi có bạn ngay
nó tả lại này tôi có một cái bảng ngay
lúc đó không có gì cả thì bây giờ tôi sẽ
in sớt một hàng mới tôi sẽ có nhưng mà
bây giờ tôi phải tìm ảnh màu biết đã mấy
ông đang đói giống như thôi mấy ông cho
mẹ nha à
hình ảnh hướng dẫn đâu nếu không sẽ ấn
tôi sẽ ấn copy email address này đường
link này cho thằng say mày không thấy có
đường link như này là sai bấm lại phát
nữa xem đó
ở đó mà không thấy có đuôi gì bây giờ ở
nhà trọ này đó tôi sẽ copy về này nó Tôi
sẽ đạt đây là bò bít
tết nó như này
em đi chợ à
Ừ ok chưa đó mình sẽ có món này thì bây
giờ
ạ bây giờ khi mà kiểu thằng mua đồ này
như tôi đã nói thì mình sẽ có kết nối
các sở liệu đã
Ồ thông báo để thể hiện mình có tác dụng
của Windows defender
đầu tiên mình sẽ có kết nối như mọi khi
mình là máy con ếch này xong rồi nó có
hot này
Ừ ông sẽ thấy nó gợi ý tiện nhà tắt Đây
nhá Nó có mốc này
khi root này
ạ sau đó thì
school này à
à À như thế tôi suýt ở đây tôi sẽ đít ở
dưới được thì bạn đợi tí Nhìn cảnh này
tôi thấy hơi khó chịu một tí tôi sẽ sửa
lại cái Speed này tí
ô ồ lắm ở được nhiều file flash này
em bận tí nhá
Anh nhìn cái này nó dễ nhìn nhé à
ạ
sau đó thì mình cứ thế êm ái kyzz đi
à à
Ê bà
có con ếch đái mày Ông thấy vợ yêu em
xin mãi câu truy vấn sẽ là select sao
far from món ăn đúng không ạ sau đó thì
que món
ngoài tên món Thì ra thế đúng không quay
gì nhé xem lại xem lại các dữ liệu phát
nhé
Em có hay bị tắt à
Anh Tuấn tắt Dragon lợi gì à
anh chạy Món ăn này món ăn có tên có vô
tên đúng không Mình sẽ lấy à mình sẽ lấy
tên bằng không phải tên bằng bò bít tết
mà mình sẽ lấy tên bằng đôla món luôn
như thế này mình sẽ ở đây có đôla món
như thế này cái đôla món này lấy ở đâu
Cái đôi món này chính từ lúc mà mình ở
bên controller mình đã khai báo ấy biến
biến món rồi nên bên này mình lấy được
Tại sao mình không thể lấy được như thế
bởi vì chiến ra là mình gọi khai báo như
này rồi mình gọi pha này lên file này nó
sẽ luôn lấy được từ bên này thì thôi đấy
à
ạ sau đó thì mai Qwerty
Paris II
Ồ không tôi không xảy ra đâu Mày không
biết tâm
mình sẽ trả về kết quả trả về kết quả
như này đó kết nối chả cần kết quả đúng
ạ à
ạ sau đó đỉ Tức là sao nghĩa là ở đây là
xem sẽ mạnh Vì nhé xem lại bên này đi
đây lấy ra bò rồi không ạ chế biến thực
ra là ở đây tôi chẳng thấy biến cái gì
cả trong trường hợp này thì tôi không
thể biến gì ở tôi thích thì tôi trả về
mỗi cái ảnh của con bò thì thôi chứ
không chế biến hình với khác trong
trường học ngày không chế biến nhé nhưng
sẽ có nhiều lúc chế biến thì thằng đầu
bếp ở thằng chế biến chứng ngoại thằng
Nhân viên là biến đổi ngoại thằng đầu
bếp sẽ chế biến chỗ này như thế này
thằng trong trường hợp này thì nó sẽ chỉ
đơn giản mà nó lấy lại kết quả thằng
nhân viên nó sẽ lấy lại kết quả Ừ đúng ạ
đứng như các bạn thấy là bởi vì mình vẫn
đang làm ở mức Cơ bản mình không có việc
là gửi món cho thằng đầu bếp và thằng
đầu bếp nó phải trả với quả của nhân
thằng nhân viên mình vẫn chưa làm phức
tạp như thế mình sẽ đơn giản là cái này
một con Thu là thằng đầu bếp làm xong là
thằng nhân viên nó cũng có thể lấy luôn
được rồi không có cái việc là gửi sang
cho là ngày và thằng này trả về như nào
mình không làm mình chưa làm bộ đấy tiếp
theo là bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ cần đơn giản
là thằng thằng nhân viên nó sẽ nó sẽ lấy
cái đĩa là xong rồi nhé cái cái món cái
kết quả này vào trong cái đĩa đấy là
được mình sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ in Plus một
cái là cái đĩa chấm p tự nhiên mình sẽ
phải tạo file này đúng không Thì sẽ tạm
phải mới là cái đĩa
ổ đĩa rồi nha nghĩa này là địa bất kỳ
cái đĩa gì cũng được Hỏi mỗi đĩa khỏi
đĩa bò bít tết mà nó sẽ một cái đĩa
không để mà về sau Tí mình có thể để cái
đĩa này
không phải mỗi bò mà đĩa này đĩa gì đó
được đĩa
cái gì đấy Ở đây tôi sẽ ở đây in tôi sẽ
ở đây có thể pp cho để in ra một cái giá
phải trả tiền kìa
Ừ thế cho cái là bởi vì là mấy ông nhớ
cái việc Khi mà mình sẽ lách như thế này
nó sẽ luôn trả về làm mà nếu là thằng
này nó sẽ luôn là thằng kiểu nó là số
nhiều ấy nên là mình muốn lấy thằng đầu
tiên thì mình sẽ là mình sẽ thường anh
khai báo kiểu như này đấy thằng đầu tiên
Factory ngay để lấy thằng đầu tiên không
ạ sau đó đi tôi sẽ ở đây là
tên này
anh
phá mình sẽ in là cái tên này nó sẽ cảnh
báo ở đây vì không tồn tại biến này
Nhưng mà không sao tím mình sẽ truyền
cảm biến này lấy tờ hàng ngày ở truyền
là cái đĩa nên nó sẽ đúng cái này bảo
lỗi cho vui thôi kệ đấy Sau đó mình sẽ
có thẻ inmate này một cái DC một cái ảnh
đi đây mình sẽ là
em hết rô đã lại Astro đôla ảnh này à
Em nói như này
bố mẹ tôi thử chạy thử mèo xem nhé
xin lỗi à
Nó đây là máy kéo y xin lỗi
ổ
đĩa bò bít tết đó hay không ạ
em thấy tui giờ nó dợ lằng nhằng nãy giờ
có thể gục hết toàn bộ cái này vào trong
một file tại sao mình lại phải học cái
lằng nhằng như thế này tạo rất nhiều pha
như này để làm gì bởi vì nó theo quy tắc
giống như cái nhà hàng vừa rồi đó là chỉ
đơn giản là
em có những thằng nó sẽ xử lý những cái
Yêu cầu có những thằng nó sẽ chỉ xử lý
những cái kiểu liên quan đến cái việc dữ
liệu Được chưa ạ
và thằng khách hàng nó sẽ chỉ được xem
những cái file nó xem file nào đó sẽ mỗi
những cái file như thế này thôi đứng
nhiên nó hơi khó hiểu chắc chắn buổi đầu
mày ông hiểu pháp luôn thì chỉ ăn tiền
quá đây là lập trình web chuyên sao rồi
nên chắc chắn là mấy ông cũng xác định
là hôm nào cũng hơi đau đầu một tí nhưng
mà tôi khẳng định cái này mà ông học thì
Java này hay ông học ở mình trang web
khác mình cũng chẳng hiểu cái gì đâu lại
như tôi thử tiết qua lại một lượt nữa
chồng mình không xem nhé đầu tiên thì
tôi vào tôi gọi được Gọi nhân viên đóng
gọn bộ bàn Chuẩn chưa Ừ cái hiểu chưa
Cái controller thành bộ bàn không ạ
thằng bồi bàn để thằng Vội Vàng đây lúc
đầu nó sẽ Bởi vì ông chưa gọi món gì
đúng ạ Nó sẽ trả về ông ấy menu Đúng
chưa Đúng chưa là nó hiểu không menu là
gì menu chỉ đơn giản là ra kiểu có một
cái đường Linh ở đây để bấm và các món
đúng không ạ
Ừ đúng chưa Đấy sau đó thì ông bấm vào
chọn chọn đấy nếu không sẽ lại nhé xem
đúng khách hàng nhìn thấy cái gì nhá
Khách hàng vừa vào đúng không hiển thị ở
cái Menu bấm vào mấy nụ bấm vào cái nó
nhìn thấy em Món này luôn Nó nó có biết
được là mấy ông xử lý file nào ông chắn
nó không ngờ truy cập vào những cái file
controller những cái file menu chấm Pepe
hay bất kỳ file nào khác nó sẽ chỉ ngồi
yên tại cái bàn thôi Đấy là điều gần như
là quan trọng nhất nếu phải nhớ trong
ngày mới xe này là khách hàng được ra ở
yên một chỗ là tại cái bàn là tại cái
Index thôi nó vẫn nằm ở file đấy nhớ nhá
Nó vẫn nằm ở file đấy Anh đã chấm TP này
bạn chất nó vẫn nằm ở cái file đã chuyển
TP thôi Được chưa đấy Có lúc mà khi
Khách hàng chọn món khách hàng bấm vào
khách hàng gọi cái món ở lên đúng không
ạ thì làm gì thằng controller nó sẽ ok
trọng trường này nó sẽ lấy cái món Khách
hàng chọn về rồi gọi đến xong rồi gọi
đến thằng đầu bếp tất cả nó sẽ truyền
cái món này anh đầu bếp thằng đầu bếp nó
sẽ rưới này đúng ạ thằng đầu bếp nó sẽ
mở tủ lạnh tất cả kết nối cơ sở liệu
đúng ạ Cái nồi cơ sở rượu đây chưa xong
mà nó sẽ lấy lấy món lấy món theo cái
tên mà khách hàng đã chọn đúng ạ sau đó
thì trả về kết quả đúng ạ chả với cái
món Đúng chưa trả với món thì thì thằng
sao nhân viên nó sẽ cầm theo cái đĩa
được chưa xong rồi nhét thêm cái món vào
trong cái đĩa đấy như thế này Đúng chưa
Rồi đưa cho khách hàng đấy nó sẽ chèn
thêm như này tôi đã đưa khách hàng sẽ là
xong thằng khách hàng nó vẫn sẽ chỉ ngồi
yên tại bàn và gọi thằng được thằng nhân
viên thôi hoa nhân viên nó sẽ làm hết
đúng không như vừa nãy tôi có phân tích
thằng nhân viên thằng chạy và làm nhiều
nhất nóng lạnh ở đấy và và mấy ông thấy
là file những cái file kiểu xử lý này
gần kia nó sẽ chỉ chứa HTML và pp để in
ra kết quả là như thế này nó sẽ không có
xử lý gì đây cả không có giống như đồ ăn
một mình kết nối đến cơ sở liệu xong
mình phân mình xử lý rất nhiều ở trong
cái file file hiển thị không cái mô hình
mới với xe nó tách ra là có những pha
chỉ để hiển thị thôi Có những file để xử
lý Có những file mà xử lý liên quan dữ
liệu thì sẽ vay riêng như thế này Đây là
mô hình một với C mô hình này nó không
phải mỗi TP mà rất nhiều ngôn ngữ khác
vẫn đang dùng mô hình này và về sau vẫn
sẽ dùng bởi vì đây mô hình mô hình kiểu
dạng là nó chuyên nghiệp nó tối ưu ở
điểm là nó dễ nó kiểu về sau mấy ông đổi
đổi đầu bếp đổi cái gì đó hay gì thì mấy
ông chỉ cần sửa tại một file những chỗ
khác nó vẫn sẽ chạy mày không hiểu gì
không cái cái cái đấy chính là mục tiêu
của lập trình chuyên sâu và visa tự học
lập trình phải nghĩ việc là khách hàng
nó sẽ thay đổi yêu cầu Chắc chắn rồi
khách hàng sẽ thay đổi rất nhiều cái
mình phải mình phải sao cho là tống nọ
chia nhỏ nó ra thành từng cái chỗ nhỏ để
mà mình dễ sửa mình sửa một chỗ tất cả
chỗ khác phải chạy
Ừ nếu nghỉ cho tôi sẽ gửi nhá
em thử cái món này tôi đang để nó là như
thế này thi ạ
Vâng tôi sẽ thêm một món mới đi
chú bò nướng ạ
ăn
cá hồi tẩm mật ong giới Tôi nhớ món này
cá hồi tẩm mật ong Thực ra là đánh em ấy
cũng phải lấy toàn bộ món này từ cơ sở
dữ liệu ra để in ra nhé chứ không phải
kiểu gõ trai nghe đâu đấy tôi sẽ
Ở trang này trên mạng để lấy cái ảnh
Ừ nếu ăn món này chưa tôi Tôi chỉ ăn
được món này tôi không ăn được hải sản
nhưng tôi chỉ ăn được món này mẹ rồi bà
kia thằng ngày có em sang
ờ ờ
em nhắn tin
có ai tự nhiên nó bị chết phải phát lại
thì chú school I
ừ ừ
Ừ ok món ăn
ở đây tôi sẽ lấy món này là cái ảnh
Ăn tỏi ngay
bên này chị đơn giản là tao không gọi
món này nữa tao quay lại bên menu đúng
không ạ
thật ra cái đoạn này nên bây giờ xuống
dòng đi thì nó rõ đi
rồi bấm vào đây đó sẽ ra đúng không ạ
Nói chuyện dàn này thôi đúng không
nó sẽ chị đơn giản thế này là kiểu nó
mấy ông thấy là tôi có phải sửa chỗ khác
không mà em thấy nó tôi phải sửa lại ở
file controller sửa lại ở phải đĩa sửa
lại bất kỳ file nào khác không còn sẽ
chỉnh sửa mỗi menu tất cả những chỗ khác
vẫn chạy cái đĩa này vẫn có thể chèn
thêm là những món khác nói chuyện Giàn
thế đúng không còn vai sao mà ông muốn
sửa do diện thì nó chỉnh sửa đúng ở mỗi
file đĩa thôi ông muốn thành đĩa sứ đĩa
gì đó nhưng ai đúng không ạ thì ông sửa
tại đúng một chỗ là con nhờ những cái
chỗ khác nó vẫn sẽ chạy đúng không Đây
là mục tiêu của cái mơ với xe đó là mấy
ông mấy lịch sử ở một nơi tất cả những
chỗ khác vẫn sẽ chạy như bình thường
vì mình không biết về các mô hình khác
như thế nào nhưng mà bây giờ em ôm mô
hình RC mình nhớ là được sử dụng nhiều
nhất là
thì mình không rõ về cái độ khó của các
mô hình đâu nhá mình biết được mỗi thế
thôi
Ừ Ok bây giờ thật là buổi hôm nay chị
học này thôi Bữa hôm nay chị gặp ngay
đấy phải rất là ngắn như này thôi nhưng
mà nhưng mà cậu với ông cũng hiểu qua về
mô hình mới C này cũng như tôi hướng dẫn
qua cài đặt cũng biết qua các thứ rồi đó
ngoạn béo nắm rõ hơn về tôi sẽ chỉ nốt
cho ông Bảy ông là bơ tôi sẽ
xe đẩy cái á
Ừ cái gì đấy Không biết này có gì luôn
kệ tôi tôi sẽ đẩy mấy cái file này lên
cho mấy ông để mấy ông có thể tham khảo
nhé
chứ không phải biết cái này cái gì vậy
Ừ tôi sẽ
xe đẩy cái này có cái ích nho
Em có sợ đây cả này
em có cái đích no để tôi nghĩa là anh lo
toàn bộ những cái thuộc thư mục nào đó
các thứ tự tiện
hỗ trợ lý Tại sao lại có cái thông của
ngài sinh ra tự động sinh gà hay đi à
cho tôi sẽ viết lại đây
à à
ừ ừ
anh hỏi xem có ngon không không không
phải chèn cái thư mục không Không tôi
không đẩy thư mục kia lên ok rồi mà tôi
sẽ đạt ở đây sẽ là mpc
cơ bản in
khi MC là gì hay cơ bản tùy cái tôi sẽ
đẩy lên như thế này Ok Bây giờ tôi đẩy
lên thế này
cần phải nhập
anh xuống
ừ ừ
cho tôi không nhớ mật khẩu tới đâu đợi
tí nữa xem Phát
10 sự thật không nhớ được mật khẩu thôi
thỉnh thoảng nó bắt đổi khó chịu với ai
ừ ừ
bí mật khẩu Tôi giá mày ông có thể ngồi
đoán
ừ ừ
A và cái này tôi nhớ không lầm mà hình
như là còn phải
dùng kia cơ chứ không phải là mật khẩu
bình thường ok đợi thì tôi lấy cái kia
vắt vào bên xuất tinh đấy à
em chịu không em
ừ ừ
Ừ đợi tao một tí để tôi đẩy nốt cốc lên
xong rồi mình kết thúc hoàng mấy ông về
kết được quên thắc mắc gì việc tranh thủ
hỏi luôn đi
đăng ký thi thật
v-app
ừ ừ
à à
ô tô
ừ ừ
ở đó rồi đồ ok ok rồi
[âm nhạc]
Em thấy có vợ chưa thấy xui trước em ơi
Ừ anh có dạy p0
bảo mật
thì web nào có dậy Phi các bạn không bị
mấy ông hỏi tôi về khóa học tôi không
vừa biết gì đâu chị
phòng to cốt trong pepperstone thì tôi
dùng cắn chôn ở cuộn chuột thôi Nếu phải
biết chỉnh cài đặt của nó Slow này để
cuộn nhớ thế
à à
Âm Nhạc
300 học nhớ ở ngay ngày đầu có Đợi tí
Đợi tí nhé
Anh mãi mãi chỉ mấy cái này cho mấy ông
ạ
Anh Hóa trang
pp tôm là zoom
bà cốt
xe tải Mau will Mau này
trên Phone site with control Zero II Ừ
tôi
khi phân tích và gái là thói quen đấy
Đây là Đấy thế là xong
Ừ cái ngày ngay cái đầu tiên
ờ ờ
Ừ ừ trên cùng là mình không để ý
Ừ để
ở Costa đẩy lên rồi đấy Mẹ không có thể
xem qua đường linh cái tháp của tôi nhé
Đây nâng cao đấy đúng không ạ
anh không thể xem qua ở đây mỗi hôm sau
mình sẽ
mình sẽ dạy cái này đương nhiên là sẽ
dạy cho mức cậu Năm dần nâng dần lên và
sẽ thay đổi cốt liên tục nên là mấy ông
phải xem lịch sử của Pocket lịch sử của
cái quen này để mấy ông theo dõi thì nó
sẽ ổn hơn cái Zippo thì Xipo Boyfriend
đâu ạ để mấy ông hiểu nắm rõ hơn tôi dậy
từ buổi tối buổi tôi sẽ có cả chú thích
các thứ từ buổi nữa Nếu anh xem
ờ ờ
Ừ thế thôi cho bữa mày phải không nhỉ
anh cũng vẫn còn 140 người đang theo dõi
ạ tuổi nghề mèo nhấn Ok nhưng mà buồn
Hôm nay chỉ đến ngưỡng thấy rồi thực ra
không ai Tôi còn định tâm sự nữa cơ
nhưng tôi xin phép Bây giờ tôi sẽ đi
chơi với bạn nữ ở
300 đi nhà hàng rồi nhé Ở 7 Bây giờ chị
ạ hôm nay mình tạm nghỉ rồi hôm sau tôi
sẽ tâm sự rất nhiều cái sau nếu không có
thắc mắc gì cứ nhắn tin bóp mày ngắn hay
bình luận và xong rồi bây giờ sau nhé
thế nhé Chào các bạn